Marvel fans have been waiting for years
for a Black Widow solo movie and from
the first trailer it looks like we're
getting some awesome action scenes and
fantastic new characters joining the MCU
including a brand new villain taskmaster
and with Marvel's history of twist
reveals for their villains and the actor
playing taskmaster currently a secret
fans have already begun to speculate
about who's really beneath the helmet
yippie guy movie lovers I'm John and in
this video I'm going to explain all the
hidden clues in the black widow teaser
the reveal taskmasters true identity and
the secret twist in the movie also keep
watching for details of an incredible
thousand dollar gift card giveaway with
bonus goodies all thanks to this video
sponsor Marvel collect buy tops quick
warning there will of course be
speculation and potential spoilers for
Black Widow as a super spy movie Black
Widow will be full of characters
double-crossing each other and hiding
secret intentions and when taskmaster is
revealed it will likely be someone
that's already close to Natasha in some
way in order to magnify the impact of
that twist potential candidates include
Florence pews Elena
Rachel vices Melina and ot Frank Ben
lays mysterious character Mason I'm
going to say straight away that Red
Guardian won't be taskmaster because
he's clearly fighting the villain in
this scene however there is another
character for Natasha's past who we also
need to consider there's a popular
theory that taskmaster is actually
Hawkeye in disguise I'm going to explain
why that's highly unlikely but first
let's review the evidence
the theory suggests the villains skilled
bow-and-arrow technique fits perfectly
with Clint Barton's expertise as an
archer
if this twist were true it would be
particularly shocking because NASA and
Clint have been great friends throughout
their time together in the MCU despite
being on opposite sides for a while
during civil war we're still friends
right
Susan are you me and spoilers for
Avengers endgame when they go to war Mia
to recover the soul stone not even
sacrifices ourselves so Clint can live
and get his own Disney Plus TV show so
their friendship and Natasha's future
sacrifice would make Hawkeye being the
twist villain in her own solo movie feel
especially Crowe
and improbable the only real way it
could make sense is if this moment is a
flashback to the time that Clint came
after Natasha on shields orders I got on
shields radar in a bad way
agent Barton was sent to kill me he made
a different call it would be pretty
weird though if Clint suited up as
taskmaster for this mission unless he'd
somehow gone rogue or was being
mind-controlled by someone else like he
was by Loki in the first Avengers movie
that all feels like a big stretch though
and the final nail in the coffin for
this theory could be that taskmaster
draws the bow with his right hand
whereas the MCU Clint is left-handed
when he uses the bow what's probably
going on in this scene is that
taskmaster has copied Hawkeye's archery
skills from a previous encounter with
him and is now using them against
Natasha
that's because taskmaster has the power
of photographic reflexes meaning he can
mimic and duplicate the moves tricks and
skills of anyone he observes another
possibility is that this is the Budapest
event that's been referenced so many
times in the nfinity saga and the
taskmaster is fighting Clint's and
imitating him in the moment you and I
remember Budapest very differently for
our next taskmaster candidate we need to
take a look at new Black Widow character
Melina Foster cough played by Rachel
Weiss who intriguingly reveals some
juicy details about Melina during an
interview at Comic Con just before we
get to that though a huge thanks to
marble collect by Tops for sponsoring
this video because December is Fan
Appreciation Month tops digital are
giving away one free collectible every
single day this month for Marvel collect
users to collect and complete the set of
30 I just signed up and have already
picked up awesome Black Widow in
spider-man cards and there are tons more
cards coming including Captain America
Thor and Iron Man and don't worry if you
miss any because you can easily collect
cards from any day you forget to sign in
now if you're a Marvel fan who wants to
prove yourself worthy you'll need to
collect five select cards in December
for a chance to win a grand prize of
$1,000 of disney.com gift cards a $250
Midtown comics digital gift card and a
hundred dollars worth of in-app currency
to spend in the marvel collect app to
enter the giveaway click the link
video-description to download the mob
will collect app register a user name
and make sure you collect all five of
the following cards spider-man Captain
America Thor Iron Man and Black Widow
the marvel collect app is available in
both the iTunes App Store and Google
Play Store worldwide and is totally free
both to download and to play there's an
enormous range of trading cars to
collect from both the MCU movies and the
original comic book characters in fact
whenever a new Marvel movie comes out
tops releases brand new cards so I'm
looking forward to collecting new Black
Widow characters like Red Guardian and
Yelena by downloading the app you can
start to collect all of your favorite
Marvel characters and as your collection
grows you'll earn awards for completing
sets and with new collectables being
released every day you can have fun
trading with fans from all over the
world
okay back to taskmaster secret identity
speaking to e w Rachel Vice explained
that Molina is a seasoned assassin who's
been through the Black Widow program
five times and that she was deeply
involved in a scientific experiment vice
then said she couldn't talk about that
any further and this itself means that
her character Molina is very likely to
factor into one of the movie's major
twists in the comics Molina vostok off
is a former Russian agent also known as
Iron Maiden
who becomes resentful of Black Widow and
attempts to kill her in the Black Widow
trailer Molina's nefarious intentions
toward Natasha aren't made obvious and
instead we see her with NAT Yelena and
Red Guardian reuniting for a meal as if
they're old friends family
big together again you gotta fit but
Molina's somewhat uncomfortable looks in
that scene suggests she could be hiding
something the scientific experiment that
Rachel vice mentioned might be the
creation of David harbors red guardian
who in the comics was the Soviet Union's
answer to Captain America or it could
also be Molina's creation of her own
iron maiden suit however I have a
feeling that Malina could actually be
responsible for creating taskmaster and
that the scientific experiment is what
ends up giving the villain its powers of
mimicry and duplication interestingly
duplication and mirroring appear to be a
theme in the black widow movie that goes
beyond taskmaster for example when we
see your lane or a Natasha fight each
other they mirror and duplicate the
other's postures and moves obviously
they were also trained under the same
system but this symbolic mirroring seems
to be something the film is pushing
through matically as well here we see
all the Black Widow operatives moving
and turning in unison and during this
aerial freefall these three mercs are
each performing the same motion
reminding me a bit of clones the real
question to ask ourselves here is
whether milena will be the person inside
the taskmaster costume or did she
experiment on somebody else well there's
actually a sneaky clue that can help
answer this in one of the other task
master scenes from the trailer when we
see the villain go up against Red
Guardian in a one-on-one fight there's
an interesting visual perspective on how
the two characters compare in terms of
height if we draw a line we can see
there's only a slight difference in
height with taskmaster appearing to be
just a little shorter than red Guardian
according to IMDB Rachel vais who plays
milena is 5 foot 6 inches tall whereas
David Harbor aka red Guardian is almost
9 inches taller at nearly 6 foot 3
that's a much bigger height difference
in this fight scene would suggest
admittedly both characters aren't
standing straight so we can't measure
the height difference exactly but they
both have their knees bent by roughly
the same amount and neither one is
wearing significantly thicker boots and
the other that would boost the height
it's unlikely therefore that this is
Melina in the taskmaster outfit now
there is actually another Black Widow
main cast member who would fit in that
costume and that's at
jyoti [ __ ] ben lay who's six-foot exactly
making him just three inches shorter
than david harbour which when we look at
this picture seems to be about the right
amount [ __ ] men lay best known for his
work in The Handmaid's Tale is playing a
character called Mason in Black Widow in
the cast interview with E W he described
Mason as a fixer the guy who can get
things done if you're a spy or superhero
and need a little bit of extra help the
actor also revealed that Mason has a bit
of a complex relationship with Natasha
and a romantic interest in her Mason's
name or Nats prior relationship with him
has never been mentioned or discussed in
previous MCU movies which could mean the
filmmakers will use that to show that
their relationship didn't go well
and Natasha never wanted to bring it up
in the comics Mason worked for shield
but he also had a freelance background
working as a covert operative where he
was simply known as the agent given
Black Widow is a super spy movie it's
also quite possible that Mason is some
kind of double agent who works both the
shield and the Russians or Molina
specifically I think it's interesting
that [ __ ] benlate uses not to reveal
which side Mason works for in the
interview with e-w especially as the
exchange is a subtle glance with Rachel
vice while describing Mason's role in
the film
he's like a fixer he's kind of you know
the guy who can get things done if
you're a spy or superhero and you need a
little bit of extra help sort you out
I'm still work
and notice how Rachel Weisz smells
knowingly to herself when the
interviewer initially asks ot to talk
about his character so Jean tell us a
little bit about the character do you
play oh yeah Mason and he's like given
all this and how little has been
revealed about oaties role in Black
Widow all Clues currently point to him
being taskmaster of course some fans
have speculated that Yelena could be
masquerading as taskmaster if we go by
the height theory though then she'd be
the least likely candidate as Florence
Pugh at around five foot forth is almost
a whole foot shorter than Red Guardian
actor David Harbor additionally given
Natasha's fate in endgame this film will
probably serve as a way to set up a new
black widow character for future MCU
movies and it looks like your Lena is
the most likely candidate for that right
now
so who do you think taskmaster really is
underneath the helmet I've created a
poll where you can vote just tap in the
top right to make your prediction and to
see the results thanks again to marvel
collect bye tops for sponsoring this
video and don't forget to download the
app from the link below and collect five
free collectables this month for a
chance to win this amazing giveaway next
tap left to check out another Marvel
video or tap write for something else
you're sure to like and if you enjoyed
this a thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers